John, do you have a single manuscript of
this injeil or psalms or Torah that you
are have been talking about that have
any of these quotes that you've been
referring to? I've mentioned manuscripts
of the New Testament earlier in our
debate. Um, do you have any manuscripts
of this inje or Torah or Psalms that
you're talking about?
Um the position of the injeil that was
in Medina is a similar position to what
the New Testament gospels are in because
you don't have any New Testament gospel.
You don't have the originals of the New
Testament gospels. All you have is later
manuscripts.
>> Yeah. Asking if you have any
>> similarly similarly with the Injeal that
was in Medina. This is not the Muslim
Injeal. This is
>> my brother. You're wasting my time. Do
you have any manuscripts of this Injeal
that you're talking about? I'm
explaining now.
>> I just It's a yes. Do you have any
manuscript?
>> Yes or no question? Yes. Yes or no
answer?
>> This one is a yes or no. If you have any
>> No. No. No. We don't have any.
>> Okay. Thank you. So, you have no
manuscripts of this in jail. You're
talking about Torah or Psalms. Okay.
Thank you. Like I mentioned, my we have
manuscripts of uh that existed before
the Quran. Can you show a verse in the
Quran that says that the Torah and the
Injil have been generally, universally,
and textually corrupted? Meaning that
all Toras, all gospels, all psalms
everywhere generally, universally, and
textually have been corrupted.
>> No. And I don't believe that.
>> Okay. So, you don't have that. Oh, you
don't believe that? Okay. No,
>> because you said it sounded like you
said that in your in your state opening
statement that you know it's been it's
been corrupt. Oh, so you're
>> all right. So, is your position then
that there is a Torah gospel and and
Psalms that are intact that are
preserved here in our realm today? No.
>> Okay. So then your position is that it
is generally textually and universally
lost and distorted
>> today. Yes.
>> So that is your position then. All
right. So can you show me?
>> Not at the time of the prophet Muhammad.
There's a difference. You you mentioned
at the time of prophet Muhammad. I'm
mentioning about today.
>> Okay. So in the time of Muhammad they
had it nice and preserved in their time
while today it's been lost. Is that your
>> I never said that. You you you said
that. Do you want me to answer? Do you
want me to give an explanation or yes or
no?
>> Oh, no, no, just simple. I mean, you can
expound if you need to, but just that I
feel like that was a simple question.
So,
>> yeah. Yeah. Just to be clear, you're
saying that the Torah and the Gospel and
the Psalms in Muhammad's time was there,
was uh uh was true, used for judgment,
but now it's gone. Now they're gone.
>> Not fully not fully known.
>> All right. So where are these where
where are can we find you know the
authentic parts of this Torah and
manuscripts
>> in the hadith.
>> In the Oh hadith.
>> Yes. In the
>> So is is the hadith Torah, Gospel and
Psalms?
>> Are the Hadith Torah, Gospel, and
>> No, the hadith are not.
>> Okay. So they're not okay. So you don't
have them.
>> Um your questions are sitting. You don't
>> Well, they're simple.
>> Maybe it's your maybe it's your
audience, but not to mine.
>> Yeah, maybe. Maybe they'll see you don't
understand it. But don't worry, I'll
elaborate.
>> I got you. You You said that the
understanding of the Torah was that it
was the Ten Commandments. Can you show
me in the Quran where it says the Torah
is the Ten Commandments?
>> No, I will show you in the Bible though.
>> Wait, why are you going to the Bible?
That's not the Torah or the Gospel or
anything?
>> I said I said in your understanding of
the Torah.
>> My understanding of the Why are you
arguing my understanding of the debate
isn't my understanding of the Torah or
anything?
>> No, the debate is does Islam affirm the
Bible? So when we're talking about the
Bible, we discussing what is the Torah
from the Christian perspective. What is
the Torah in that Bible?
>> No, I made I made clear of what I was
proving today that your Quran affirms
when we're talking about the Bible
specifically. The Torah, the Gospel, and
the Psalms that it mentions.
>> Okay.
>> So, so that's
>> And is the Ten Commandments in the
Bible?
>> The Ten Commandments are in the Torah.
Yes.
>> In the in the Pentatuk, right?
>> They're in the Torah.
>> Okay. Yes.
>> You affirm that the Ten Commandments are
in the Torah?
>> Do you mean Do you mean Do you mean the
Pentatuk?
>> I'm trying to understand. You
understand? What what is the pentatue?
>> The the first five books of the Bible.
>> And what are the first five books of the
of Moses also called?
>> The Pentatue.
>> What else?
>> The books of Moses.
>> Come on.
>> The Torah. The Torah.
>> All right. All right. Let's try this
again.
>> I'm just trying to I'm trying to
>> Yeah, let's let's try this again. The
first five books of Moses, Hold on. The
first five books of Moses are identified
as the Pentatuk, which is also known as
what, John?
>> The the what is labeled today? The
Torah. Yes.
>> Thank you. So the five the the pentatuk
is known as the Torah. So you affirm
that the ten commandments are in the
Torah. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> Thank you very much. You just you just
gave me
>> and I affirmed that the ten commandments
according to Moses was the Torah itself.
>> I got you. I got you. Um
>> in Deuteronomy 27 8-10 it says that the
Moses's concept of the Torah was what
was on the stones. This is pre before
this is before the pentatuk was even
written.
>> I got you.
>> So mo Moses says
>> uh you know where you getting this from?
>> And you shall you shall write every
clear clearly all of the words of on
this Torah
>> on these stones. That's all. So so the
concept of Torah according to Moses was
on the tablets.
>> Is that true?
>> Now later.
>> Wait wait wait. You're wasting you're
draining my time because I didn't ask on
this. Is that true?
>> Okay.
>> Is that true? Is that true of what what
you just read from the from the Torah
that we have today? Is that true? That
the ten commandments were on the tablet?
>> No, we can't we can't I can't affirm or
deny.
>> But I am I'm asking you to affirm or
deny right now because this is the
debate. I'm asking
>> I can't I can't Islam Islam does not
speak whether it is ten commandments or
not.
>> So then don't Yeah, it does. Your your
Quran does mention the ten commandments.
It just doesn't tell us whether it's the
Torah or not. The hadith mentioned ten
commandments, but we don't know if that
was the Torah. We don't know if it had
more or less or anything. What I'm
saying to you is your concept of the
Torah, Moses's concept of the Torah.
According to what you told the Torah,
>> how do you know Moses? Wait, wait. How
do you know Moses's concept of the
Torah?
>> I'm saying according to you, Moses.
>> No, that's not according to me. You said
according to Moses. How do you know
Moses?
>> Okay, let me rephrase it.
>> Okay. According to you,
>> Moses's concept of the Torah
>> was what was on the tablets.
>> All right. Thank you. According to
Moses, what was the Torah?
>> According to Moses, what was the Torah?
>> Yes.
>> The book that was revealed.
>> What was that? You're just saying what
was that?
>> What do you mean what was that?
>> What was that? When when Moses was to
open up the Torah or recite the Torah to
the people, what was he using? What did
he have? What did the people have?
>> What do you mean? What did the people
have at what time? What? When? Because
you're talking about Moses. What was
Moses's understanding of what the Torah
was? What was he reading to the people?
What were
>> It was a book from Allah.
>> It was a book that was revealed from
Allah to him.
>> You're not telling me what it was.
>> We don't know. We don't have details on
on what it is.
>> Oh, no. No way. You don't know what it
is. So, if you don't know what it is,
then you can't tell me what it's not.
You can't tell me that. Wait, wait.
Stop. Stop. We can't We can't tell you.
>> My time. Habibi. This is my time.
Because your concept is
time and that's not our concept.
>> James, he's cutting me off on my time
for some reason. Is my mic m like not
going or something?
>> On mute. I'd be the same way in terms of
protective of my time.
>> But in some cases, I
>> I want to let John finish if it's in the
ballpark of what's relevant. But I don't
blame you for wanting to protect your
time. I'll give you 30 seconds back just
because my own dialogue my own speech
here has been so long.
>> Okay. Yeah. I I I'd like him to finish
too just as long but when he goes starts
going off and on, you know, that that's
that's where I try to cut it. Like let's
try to keep it concise. All right. So,
thank you. You said that you don't know
what Moses's understanding of the Torah
was. Um and so and you don't know what
the Torah was at all. So therefore, you
can't tell me what it's not.
>> I never said that.
>> You did. You clearly just said you don't
you don't know what the Torah was or
what Moses is understood. words in my
mouth.
>> You just said that. Okay.
>> You're putting the words in my mouth and
you expect a yes or no answer.
>> What was the was the inj?
>> Yes.
>> By who?
>> By Jesus and his companions.
>> All right. Can you show me the Quran
where it says Jesus wrote the inje or
give me a one hadith that says Jesus
wrote the inje?
>> Not on me. No, I can't give you that
name.
>> So where are you getting this from? That
Jesus wrote the inje.
>> We have evidence that it was written
from
>> I know. By who? from from Allah. It says
it's written.
>> No, no, that's what I mean. What is your
evidence of who wrote it?
>> Well, I'm It's an inference like your
inference about the the Bible being in
Medina.
>> So, you don't know. Is that correct?
>> It's an inference bas inference from
where? An inference from where?
>> If you if you don't think inferences we
can know through inference, then you've
lost this debate.
>> An inference from where?
>> Your whole point about the Bible being
in Medina is an inference. My inference
is that Jesus wrote it. If he didn't
write it, it would have been his
companions.
>> Well, I gave you I gave you warus
explicitly saying that the that the go
that the gospel is there in where
Muhammad is. So, here's my question to
you. When you say when you say you have
an inference, when you say you have an
inference, you're going on an inference
that Jesus wrote the gospel where
>> all his companions.
>> Huh?
>> All his companions.
>> Well, you said Jesus or his when you're
saying Jesus, so I'm attacking that. or
unless you want to let that go. Do you
affirm the writer wrote the gospel?
>> Let me clarify.
>> Okay.
>> When we say wrote, I don't want you to
misunderstand this to mean the words of
Jesus or his companions. I mean simply
recording what Allah has given to Jesus.
>> Is it you have to be technical here. The
point is that Jesus was given the okay
and either Jesus or his companions would
have recorded the words of Allah that
Allah gave Jesus. This does not mean
that this is written in in the sense
that it's the words of Jesus or the
words of the companions of Jesus as the
New Testament gospels came to be.
>> I understand. I understand. I
understand. Okay. So, your understanding
is that Jesus or the comp or his
companions the companions of Jesus would
have written down what he was preaching
what he what God has revealed.
>> Yeah, that's my infant.
>> All right. Nice. Okay. Um, according to
the Christians, uh, would the companions
of Jesus, at least some of them at
least, have written down, uh, the
revelation that he was bringing up the
gospel?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, it sounds like to me that you have
the same understanding of the gospel
that I do, that the companions of Jesus
would have written down the revelation
that he was preaching about. Thank you
so much. Um,
>> it sounds like that's you. Do you want
me to answer? You want me to respond or
you just put words in my mouth?
>> Oh, yeah. I just got a question. Does
this
>> Would you like a response?
>> I got a question. Did you argue with us
once?
>> No, it's not a I didn't ask you anything
>> because you you the people know that's
not what I said.
>> I didn't ask you anything.
>> Technically,
if we're sticking to strictly questions,
then uh I've got to hold you to it,
Avery. That if you summarize it in a way
that John doesn't like, I do have to
kind of press you to only ask questions
to John.
>> True. True. That's fair enough. Fair
enough. My My bad, John. My bad. Yeah,
because he because Au is misrepresenting
my position.
>> I didn't misrepresent you at all. I'm
just quoting you verbatim.
>> It's a question.
>> Okay. Um Okay. So, let's see here. Um
so, you So, okay. So, you so you
understand that Christians would have
had this belief that uh the companions
of Jesus would have written down the
gospel um
>> recorded.
>> Is it Do you have a question? Are you
>> Yeah, I'm building up to my question.
>> I'm building up to my question right
here. So you have that question of that
and you have that understanding that the
companions would have written the in
the companions of Jesus. Stop
interrupting so I can ask my question.
>> I can't hear you.
>> I'm I'm loading up. Is my my volume
good?
>> Okay.
>> So were the companions of Jesus
believers?
>> The companions. Of course
>> they were believers. Okay. Um it says in
chapter 61:6 that Allah would have uh he
made the disbelievers of Jesus
victorious over the disbelievers of
Jesus. And in chapter 3 verse 55 it says
that they will be victorious and remain
victorious over the disbelievers until
the day of resurrection. So
>> yeah,
>> was Allah did Allah keep his promise in
ma making sure that the followers of
Jesus were victorious in spreading his
message?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So that means that the that the
disbelievers never successfully uh
distorted or got rid of the message of
the followers of Jesus, right?
>> No.
>> Uh like are you affirming or denying?
Sorry.
>> Do you want me to explain?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. If you want to understand what the
huh
>> if you can in like 30 seconds because I
don't know how much
>> Okay. If you want to understand what the
what this verse means go to the taps.
The taps says that this was fulfilled by
the coming of Islam
>> and the true followers of of Isa the
remnants of them who were around
accepted Islam
>> and became Muslim. And it's Islam that
is dominant which is clearly dominant
over uh the world today.
>> Yeah.
>> Over over how long how long Yeah, I got
you. How long were understanding of
this. If you go to the taps here, it's
referring to them who actually this was
fulfilled by the coming of Islam.
>> I got you. So, I'm I'm looking at I just
want to just give a if we're doing this
um in Tapsir, he mentions how this is
talking about even the believers in
Jesus's time. And also Jala says the
believers in Jesus' time and those that
will follow them that they uh will
continue to be victorious over the
disbelievers not only in battle but also
in argument meaning in religious debate.
>> Yeah, that's correct. Correct. Okay,
that's correct. Okay, good. So
>> the way the way that happened is through
Martin through being shahed.
>> Yeah. But was there any was there any
was there ever a time was there ever a
time
>> answer or not?
>> Yeah. Well, this is my question. Was
there ever a time where the followers of
Jesus were not uppermost over the
disbelievers?
>> I think your your understanding of
uppermost is that they will be the most
dominant. That's
>> that's what it says.
>> It doesn't mean they're the most
dominant.
>> Yeah. Well, Gelain says they are
dominant in in argument and they are
dominant in battle. So when it comes to
religious belief and debate, they win.
And when it comes to battle, they win as
well.
I don't know what you what you what
>> that's jalain jalain taps
>> yeah I don't I'm not sure what this what
what point you're trying to make the
point I'm saying is the tap of this
>> to answer this to it was answered with
the coming of Islam
>> and with the uh the initial followers of
Jesus it was answered with their
martinom the fact that they will be
victorious going to Jenna through being
martyrs
>> but none of the
>> I got you none of the tops here says
that they will be victorious through
martyrdom. It says that they'll be
victorious through argument.
>> Don't say that.
>> This is I I it's not an IT that this
says. Can you do you have a top seal
that they're victorious in martyrdom?
>> I'll have to check. I don't have no
>> Okay. For sure. So, uh everything that
I'm looking at, Jalain, Maduri, they all
mention how they're uh there is talk
about their belief system and their
battle and their and their numbers them
being dominant. Which group uh were were
accurately conveying the message of
Jesus? Because it's like, let me ask you
this.
>> So, who's the dominant Christian group?
Catholics.
>> Exactly.
>> Are you Catholic? Are you a Catholic?
>> Well, well, well, God bless the
Catholics. They're trinit. Wait, wait,
just No, you can't ask me questions. You
can ask me later.
God bless the Catholics. Hold on,
brother. Let me let me ask my question,
bro. Let me ask my question. You said
that you said that the dominant group
were the Catholic are the Catholics,
which you just
excuse me. You just gave me the debate
because
>> I want to give Avery a chance to ask
this last question and we've only got
like several seconds and we'll give John
a chance to respond but we're
>> I don't want to cut you off mid uh
question. So if you're able to ask this
question, Avery, we'll let John respond
and then we have to go to the next
section.
>> Beautiful. Beautiful. Since you said
that the dominant uh the dominant group
are the Catholics and Allah says that
the believers the followers of Jesus
will remain dominant uppermost over the
disbelievers
from the from then all the way till the
day of judgment. Does that mean that all
that the Catholics are actually the true
believers or did Allah fail to keep his
promise and the disbelievers actually
succeeded?
>> Is that your question?
>> Yes sir. Yeah, I mean I would just go to
the taps of this which is it was
fulfilled by the coming of Islam.